good morning John thanks for joining me
in our brand new format which I'm sure
we will bring back again but today
instead of that I'm back in the old
space and I'm going to do an old format
this one is the one where you ask Google
what questions people have been asking
by starting to ask it a question and not
finish good old Google autocomplete why
is there an egg shortage well broadly it
is because we build many systems for
efficiency rather than resilience if you
want to make a lot of eggs really cheap
you got to have one very big room with a
whole lot of chickens in it but that's
also a fantastic circumstance for the
transmission of disease like bird flu in
order to control diseases Farmers have
to kill all of the birds in a facility
when one bird gets bird flu and then
disinfect the whole place over 60
million birds have been killed in the
current bird flu outbreak and that
decreases the number of eggs on the
market while demand stays roughly the
same five dollars for a dozen eggs is a
lot of money compared to what we were
spending this time last year but a
dollar 33 for a dozen eggs which is what
we were spending this time last year is
a price that some would argue should be
a little bit bit higher to allow for
more resiliency in that system why is
the sky blue the white light that comes
from the sun is made of a bunch of
different wavelengths that all look
different colors to us the gases in our
atmosphere are good at scattering blue
wavelengths out of the white light so
the sun with the blue ticking out looks
a little bit yellow while the sky with a
blue scattering around looks like blue
but as I have said before the sky
doesn't exist It's Just an Illusion a
kind of one colored rainbow why is my
poop green could be a lot of different
things uh probably something you ate
either it's a bunch of green vegetable
stuff or green food coloring or maybe
some antibiotics or different
medications will turn your poop green if
it's accompanied by diarrhea or other
symptoms that have been going on for
multiple days go see a doctor I'm not a
doctor and neither is the internet why
is my eye twitching I don't know same
though maybe it's because of the this we
don't actually know why I was twitched
though it's definitely correlated with
fatigue and stress and if you don't have
one or the other or both of those
well done I'm just I'm loving that for
you I'm not I'm fine why is the flag at
half mass in the U.S and probably other
places definitely Canada now that I
found this clip when mourning something
we often put the flag only halfway up
this is sometimes because of like big
National tragedies that are in the news
but it's also often because of the death
of a member of the government or some
public servant and it varies from state
to state flag Express which sells flags
keeps track of this on their website so
you can always know if you want to why
is my poop black this is significantly
more concerning and less common than
green poop you should probably go see a
doctor immediately it could be because
you're bleeding somewhere in your GI
tract why is it called Black Friday well
At the moment I'm thinking it has
something to do with poop but I know
that that can't be right so I'll look it
up I guess I looked it up and I'm gonna
be honest with you it's boring it's like
oh there's a lot of traffic on the day
after Thanksgiving on the roads people
didn't like that why is JJ Watt retiring
I don't know man that sounds like a
pretty personal question why is these
diesel so expensive well it's taxed a
little bit higher so that makes it a
little bit more expensive also recently
we started to require in the US low
sulfur diesel because of the human
health consequences of having all that
sulfur in the air the biggest reason is
that when you have a barrel of crude oil
the part that can get turned into
gasoline is fairly big and it's more
flexible that part can be used for a
bunch of different stuff that's like
high value and low value and you can
sort of mix up the market based on
what's most needed and most expensive
well the part that can get turned into
diesel is smaller and the stuff it can
get turned into is more valuable than
diesel like jet fuel so there's just
more higher value demand for the diesel
fraction of the crude which drives up
the price and our final question in the
Google autocomplete list why is my dog
shaking and gosh I don't know that that
sounds scary I'm sorry about your dog it
could be stress anxiety nervousness cold
excitement but if this is a new thing
and you're worried about it again I'm
not a doctor of animals or people so
maybe you should go see the vet John
after 16 years I still love making
videos with you why is this so much fun
I don't know but I like it and I'll see
you on Tuesday